THE STAR-STUDDED EVENT ON MAY
16TH.
AINSLEY: THAT’S GREAT.
LET’S BRING IN THE SECOND LADY
OF THE UNITED STATES.
MS. KAREN PENCE AND LEAD
AMBASSADOR FOR NEW MENTAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
I DO HAVE TO ASK YOU ABOUT YOUR
HUSBAND NOT WEARING A MASK WHEN
HE WAS NOT TOURING THE MAYO
CLINIC?
>> THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION AS
OUR MEDICAL EXPERTS HAVE TOLD US
WEARING A MASKS PREVENTS YOU
FROM SPREADING THE DISEASE AND
KNOWING THAT HE DOESN’T HAVE
COVID-19, HE DIDN’T WEAR ONE.
IT WAS ACTUALLY AFTER HE LEFT
MAYO CLINIC THAT HE FOUND OUT
THAT THEY HAD A POLICY OF ASKING
EVERYONE TO WEAR A MASK.
SOMEONE HAS WORKED ON THIS WHOLE
TASK FORCE FOR OVER 2 MONTHS IS
NOT SOMEONE WHO WOULD HAVE DONE
ANYTHING TO OFFEND ANYONE OR
SCARE ANYONE.
I’M GLAD THAT YOU GAVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
AINSLEY: THANK YOU FOR COMING ON
AND TALKING ABIT.
SO SUICIDE, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
UP.
WE GOT THE JOBLESS NUMBERS
30 MILLION PEOPLE WITHOUT JOBS
BECAUSE OF COVID.
MENTAL HEALTH IS ON THE
FOREFRONT IN OUR MINDS.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> THE PRESIDENT ORDERED 3-YEAR
TASK FORCE CALLED PREVENT AND
IT’S THE PRESIDENT’S ROAD MAP TO
EMPOWER VETERANS AND THE
NATIONAL TRAGEDY OF SUICIDE AND
PREVENT HAS STARTED A MENTAL
HEALTH CAMPAIGN CALLED MORE THAN
EVER BEFORE.
RIGHT NOW THERE’S THIS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE THAT ALL OF US ARE
DEALING WITH, EVERYBODY,
AINSLEY, IS STRUGGLING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH RIGHT NOW AND SO
WE SEE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET THE STIGMA TAKEN AWAY FROM
MENTAL HEALTH BECAUSE WE ALL
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE FEEL LIKE
RIGHT NOW AND MORE THAN EVER
BEFORE HAS FOUR MAIN POINTS,
FIRST OF ALL, CHECK IN WITH
YOURSELF EVERY DAY, HOW ARE YOU
DOING.
SECONDLY, WHAT ARE THE THINGS
THAT HELP YOU, WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT GET YOU OUT OF THE
LOW MOOD WHETHER IT’S READING OR
COOKING OR GARDENING, AND THEN
SCHEDULE THOSE THINGS INTO YOUR
DAY, GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF
STRUCTURE TO THIS, YOU KNOW,
OPEN-ENDED DAY THAT WE ARE ALL
DEALING WITH.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT
THEIR STRUGGLES AND THEIR
SUCCESSES ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE
CHILDREN AT HOME AND THEY’RE
WORRIED ABOUT WHEN AM I GOING TO
PLAY SOCCER AGAIN OR WHEN DO I
GET TO SEE MY TEACHER, I DON’T
LIKE THE FACT THAT MY SENIOR
PROM WAS CANCELED, LET THEM GOES
THE FEELINGS OUT, TALK ABOUT THE
STRUGGLES.
IT’S OKAY NOT TO BE OKAY.
BUT THEN TALK ABOUT THE
SUCCESSES, WHAT ARE SOME THINGS
YOUR FAMILY HAS LEARNED ABOUT
YOURSELF OVER THIS TIME, WHAT
ARE SOME THINGS THAT YOU’VE
ACCOMPLISHED AND LASTLY, IF
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING, IF YOU’RE
WORRIED ABOUT YOURSELF OR
SOMEONE YOU LOVE, WE ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO CALL THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE AT
(800)273-8255 AND IF YOU’RE
MILITARY, WE ALSO WANT YOU   TO
GO TO MILITARY ONE FORCE, THAT’S
A POLICE WHERE WE PROVIDE FREE
COUNSELING FOR MILITARY MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AN WE
ALSO WANT PEOPLE TO GO TO
FACEBOOK.COM/WEAREPREVENT AND
CLICK ON LEARN MORE AND WILL
GIVE YOU LOTS OF RESOURCES BUT
WE WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT WE
ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER AND WE
ARE ALL FEELING STRESSES RIGHT
NOW AND WE WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
THERE’S HELP OUT THERE.
IT’S OKAY TO NOT BE OKAY.
AINSLEY: YES, WHAT A BEAUTIFUL
MESSAGE AND I FEEL PRIVILEGE
TODAY BE ABLE TO TALK TO YOU AND
SPREAD THE MESSAGE TO OUR
COUNTRY BECAUSE SO MANY ARE
HURTING AND IF WE CAN PREVENT
ONE LIFE, ONE PERSON ARE TAKING
THEIR LIFE HOPEFULLY WE’VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT, CALL THAT
NUMBER.
YOUR VALUE, YOU’RE GOD’S CHILD
AND GOD HAS BIG PLANS FOR YOUR
LIFE.
KAREN PENCE.
YOU’RE WELCOME, GO TO OUR